est la strophe le ministère de la santé
vient de diffuser cette brochure
elle est destinée en priorité aux
professionnels de la santé qui ont à
soigner les victimes
objectif prioritaire mettre en garde
contre une nouvelle forme d'activité des
sectes qui sont de plus en plus présente
auprès des personnes touchées par des
sinistres naturels ou industriels
derrière l'aide matérielle il y a
parfois l'embrigadement celle en quête
de cette édition les signes et
christelle bertrand edwards père sans
prévenir ils ont débarqué à 150
ils ont travaillé sans relâche pendant
deux jours ces témoins de jéhovah n'ont
rien demander en retour
ce document amateur en témoigne au
lendemain des inondations dans l'aude
cette maison de retraite a besoin de
bras pour nettoyer ils ont été prévenus
par un des fournisseurs de la maison de
retraite lui même témoin de jéhovah en
arrivant sur place les adeptes savait
qu'il n'y avait plus de résidents tous
évacué la veille
la directrice de l'établissement assure
qu'à aucun moment elle n'a entendu un
témoin de jéhovah distiller sa bonne
parole pas de prosélytisme donc mais les
témoins de jéhovah ont marqué des points
auprès des sinistrés sont les témoins de
jéhovah ou où la croix rouge la croix
rouge nous a aidés aussi les militaires
nous ont été pour moi c'était une aide
mais bon c'était
on en avait besoin à cette période là
une période douloureuse pour les
habitants des communes du sud ouest de
la france
des inondations meurtrières
traumatisante pour des milliers de
personnes d'une seconde à l'autre elles
deviennent victime fragile les lieux de
catastrophe
du pain béni pour les sectes l aide qu
occupe le terrain et redorent leur image
sonia jungla étudie les sectes depuis 30
ans par ces consultations
elle a observé la montée d'un nouveau
prosélytisme s'ils viennent aider les
gens s'ils font partie des sauveurs des
sauveteurs ce sont des personnes qui
sont formidables qui font partie du bien
elles sont de l'autre côté ce ne sont
plus des sectes mauvaises ce sont des
sauveurs très bon qui viennent pour
aider les victimes
donc il passe de l'autre côté il va y
avoir toute cette notoriété aussi qu'ils
vont pouvoir récupérer sur les lieux de
catastrophe
les témoins de jéhovah n'ont pas
souhaité nous rencontrer
ils disent ne pas se sentir visés par
les mises en garde du ministère de la
santé oms septembre new york
les scientologues sont reconnaissables
il porte un tee shirt jaune mêler aux
secouristes
ils aident réconforte et quelques
semaines plus tard leurs actions se
retrouve en bonne place sur leur site
internet
c'est la première fois que la
scientologie se serrent publiquement
d'une catastrophe pour faire sa
publicité
dix jours plus tard 21 septembre 2001
explosion de l usine azf à toulouse
moins visible qu'à new york les
scientologues ont distribué des milliers
de tracts dans les boîtes aux lettres
des riverains de lusine mona vasquez est
une des victimes du prosélytisme
scientologues
elle avait 18 ans elle est restée
adeptes dix ans aujourd'hui elle est
artiste peintre elle vite au calme
proche de ses racines son livre c'est sa
thérapie
elle explique qu un scientologue efforcé
de recruter de nouveaux adeptes
tous les jours il rendait compte à sa
hiérarchie si les statistiques bes c'est
la sanction
je me suis retrouvée par exemple en une
matinée il fallait que je fasse tous les
carreaux de l'hôtel sans produit sans
éponge saharienne donc je fallait que je
me débrouille avec du papier journal de
l'eau frotter et en plus super g t elle
une sorte de juge de passer après pour
vérifier que c'était bien fait et
c'était mal fait si les coins des
carreaux été mal fait il fallait que je
le recommence c'était une vraie punition
c'était vraiment tout pour avilir la
personne les trouver retire et la rendre
l'infantiliser éviter qu'une victime de
catastrophes soit aussi victime d'une
secte le ministère de la santé tire le
signal d'alarmé et appelle les services
de secours à la vigilance